strategy is just prioritizing it's how
you choose to allocate resources that
are limited against unlimited options
that is strategy and the tough part
about strategy in general is that when
you're looking you have all these
options strategy is figuring out
actually there's one that's right here
that takes us off the page cu the most
costly thing in business isn't just the
unknowns but it's the unknown unknowns
as in the things that you didn't even
know you could pick from and some of the
biggest strategic moves are outside the
board and that's where sometimes having
other people Etc is helpful because you
have outside eyes your mouth inch below
your nose but you still need somebody
else to sell you a bad breath